[Music]
so
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
accompanied by the prime minister of the
state
of israel his highness the minister of
foreign affairs
and international cooperation of the
united arab emirates
and the minister of the foreign affairs
of the kingdom
of bahrain
[Music]
thank you very much please thank you
the first lady and i are honored to
welcome to the white house
prime minister netanyahu of israel
and mrs netanyahu thank you so much
thank you sarah
and foreign minister abdullah
bin zayed
united arab emirates uae thank you very
much
and foreign minister abdul nazif
al-zhani of bahrain thank you
thank you very much
we're here this afternoon to change the
course of history
after decades of division and conflict
we mark the dawn of a
new middle east thanks to the great
courage of the leaders of these three
countries we take a major stride toward
a future in which people of all faiths
and backgrounds live together in peace
and prosperity
in a few moments these visionary leaders
will sign the first two peace deals
between
israel and the arab state
in more than a quarter century
in israel's entire history there have
previously been only two such agreements
now we have
achieved two in a single month
and there are more to follow
[Applause]
israel the united arab emirates and
bahrain
will establish embassies exchange
ambassadors
and begin the cooperate and work
together
so strongly to cooperate as partners
across the
broad range of sectors from tourism to
trade and health care
to security they're going to work
together
they are friends the abraham accords
also opened the door for muslims around
the world to visit the historic sites
in israel and to peacefully pray
at al-aqsa mosque in jerusalem the third
holiest site
in islam
together these agreements will serve as
the foundation for a comprehensive piece
across the entire region
something which nobody thought was
possible certainly not
in this day and age maybe in many
decades from now
but one founded on shared interest
mutual respect and friendship
to our honored guests from israel the
united arab emirates and bahrain
congratulations on this outstanding
achievement congratulations
[Applause]
i also want to thank vice president mike
pence thank you mike
great job
secretary of state mike pompeo mike
thank you very much
national security adviser robert o'brien
robert thank you
mr jared kushner jared thank you very
much
ambassador brian hook thank you very
much brian
thank you thank you and avi
berkowitz avi thank you very much
i also want to give a very special
thanks he's been
an incredible ambassador to israel david
friedman
that's a very uh great group of people
great group of patriots they wanted this
to happen so badly they worked so hard
and again nobody thought it could happen
and they thought it could happen they
never even doubted it so i want to thank
you all very much thank you
for generations the people of the middle
east have been held back by old
conflicts hostilities
lies treacheries so many things held
them back
actually lies that the jews and arabs
were
enemies and that al-aqsa
mosque was under attack constantly they
would say it was
under attack these lies passed down from
generation to generation
fueled a vicious cycle of terror and
violence that spread across the region
and all over the world
these agreements prove that the nations
of the region are breaking free from the
failed
approaches of the past today's signing
sets history on a new course
and there will be other countries very
very soon
that will follow these great leaders
the people of the middle east will no
longer allow hatred of israel to be
fomented as an excuse for radicalism
or extremism so important and they'll no
longer allow the great destiny of their
region to be denied
on my first foreign trip as president i
had the honor of addressing the leaders
of more than
54 arab and muslim nations
in saudi arabia my message that day was
very simple
i urge the nations of the middle east to
set aside their differences
unite against the common enemy of
civilization
and work together toward the noble aims
of security
and prosperity i offered america's
friendship
i offered america's help but i said
clearly that the
nations of the regions had to decide
what kind of a future they wanted for
their children
and for their families and for their
nation itself
no one could make that choice for them
they had to do that themselves
today the world sees that they're
choosing cooperation
over conflict friendship over enmity
prosperity over poverty and hope over
despair
they are choosing a future in which
arabs and israelis
muslims
and dream together side by side in
harmony
community and peace once again let me
congratulate the
people of israel the people of the
united arab
emirates and the people of the kingdom
of bahrain
god bless you all this is an incredible
day for the world this
is a really wonderful and beautiful
occasion i want to thank all of the
members of congress for being here
senators congressmen congresswoman we
just appreciate it so much
everybody wanted to be here it's a very
important day for the world it's a very
important day for peace before the party
signed the accords i'd like to ask prime
minister netanyahu to say a few words
followed by
the foreign minister of the united arab
emirates
and the foreign minister of bahrain
thank you very much
it's a great honor thank you
our dear friend president trump
first lady melania trump
thank you for hosting me my wife sarah
and our entire delegation on this
historic day i want to recognize vice
president pence
secretary pompeo national security
adviser o'brien
and other cabinet members jared kushner
avi berkowitz
ambassador friedman and other members of
the president's able peace team
senators members of congress israeli
ambassador
ron durmer his emirates and bahraini
counterparts
as well as all the dignitaries gathered
here
on this sunny day i want to
also express my gratitude for all the
israelis
who worked for years uh sometimes
in less sunny climbs to bring this date
and i thank each
and every one of you thank you
ladies and gentlemen mr president
this day is a pivot of history
it heralds a new dawn of peace
for thousands of years the jewish people
have prayed for peace
for decades the jewish state has prayed
for peace
and this is why today we're filled
with such profound gratitude
i am grateful to you president trump for
your decisive leadership
you have unequivocally stood by israel's
side
you have boldly confronted the tyrants
of tehran
you've proposed a realistic vision for
peace
between israel and the palestinians and
you have successfully brokered
the historic peace that we are signing
today
a peace that has brought support in
israel
in america in the middle east indeed
in the entire world
i'm grateful to crown prince muhammad
bin zayed
of the united arab emirates and to you
foreign minister abdullah bin zayed
i thank you both for your wise
leadership and for working with the
united states and israel
to expand the circle of peace
i am grateful
i am grateful to king muhammad of
bahrain and to you
foreign minister abdul latif al-zayani
for joining us
joining us in bringing hope
to all the children of abraham
to all of israel's friends in the middle
east
those who are with us today
and those who will join us tomorrow i
say
assalamu alaikum peace unto thee
shalom
and you've heard from the president that
he is already
lining up more and more
countries this is unimaginable a few
years ago
but with resolve determination a fresh
look at the way peace
is done this is being achieved thank you
mr president
ladies and gentlemen the people of
israel
well know the price of war
i know the price of war i was wounded in
battle
a fellow soldier a very close friend of
mine
died in my arms
my brother yoni lost his life while
leading his soldiers
to rescue hostages held by terrorists at
antebe
my parents grief over the loss of yoni
was unrelieved until their dying day
and over the years when i have come to
console the families of israel's fallen
soldiers
and victims of terror i have seen
that same grief countless times
and this is why i am so deeply moved to
be here today
for those who bear the wounds of war
cherish the blessings of peace
and the blessings of the peace we make
today
will be enormous
first because this peace will eventually
expand
to include other arab states and
ultimately it can end the arab
israeli conflict once and for all
second because the great economic
benefits
of our partnership will be felt
throughout our region
and they will reach every one of our
citizens
and third this is not only a peace
between leaders
it's a peace between peoples
israelis emiratis and bahrainis are
already embracing one another we are
eager to invest in a future of
partnership
prosperity and peace we've already begun
to cooperate on combating corona
and i'm sure that together we can find
solutions to many of the problems
that afflict our region and beyond
so despite the many challenges and
hardships that we all face
despite all that let us pause for a
moment
to appreciate this remarkable day
let us rise above any political divide
let us put all cynicism aside
let us feel on this day the pulse
of history for long after the pandemic
is gone
the peace we make today will endure
ladies and gentlemen i have devoted my
life
to securing israel's place among the
nations
to ensure the future of the one and only
jewish state to accomplish that goal
i work to make israel strong very strong
for history has taught us that strength
brings security
strength brings allies and ultimately
and this is something president trump
has said again
and again ultimately strength
brings peace
king david expressed this basic truth
thousands of years ago
in our eternal capital jerusalem his
prayer
immortalized in the book of psalms in
the bible
echoes from our glorious past and guides
us
towards a brilliant future
may god give strength to his people may
god
bless his people with peace
mr president
distinguished guests this week is rosh
hashanah
the jewish new year and what a blessing
we bring to this new year a blessing of
friendship
a blessing of hope a blessing
of peace thank you
ladies and gentlemen his highness the
minister of foreign affairs
and international cooperation of the
united arab
emirates
mr president mr prime minister
and my friend abdullah zayani
distinguished guests salaam alaika
let me start by conveying the best
regards of the uae people
and the leadership and especially
you mr president and everyone gathered
here today
i'll continue my speech in arabic and
i'm sure there will be translation to
that
acapella
i stand here today to extend a hand of
peace and receive a hand of peace
in our faith we say oh god you are peace
and from you
comes peace the search for peace is an
innate principle
yet principles are effectively realized
when they are
transformed into action today we already
we are already
witnessing a change in the heart of the
middle east
a change that will send hope around the
world
[Applause]
enrique
this is this initiative would not have
been possible without the efforts
of his excellency president donald trump
and his team who worked hard and
sincerely for us
all to reach here most notably my
counterpart
secretary of state mike pompeo and jared
kushner
senior adviser to the president of the
united states
and all those who are genuine about the
principle of peace in the united states
who have strived to realize this major
achievement
thank you
[Applause]
deutsche is
your excellency prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
prime minister of the state of israel
thank you
for choosing peace and for halting the
annexation of palestinian territories
a decision that reinforces our shared
will
to achieve a better future for
generations to come
foreign
ladies and gentlemen we are witnessing
today
a new trend that will create a better
path for the middle east
this peace accord which is a historic
achievement for the united
states of america the state of israel
and the united arab emirates will
continue to have
a positive impact as we believe that
its reverberations will be reflected on
the entire region
every option other than peace would
signify
destruction poverty and human suffering
this new vision which is beginning to
take shape as we meet today for the
future of the region
full of youthful energy is not a slogan
that we raise for political gain
as everyone looks forward to creating a
more stable
prosperous and secure future
at a time when science is prevailing the
region the region's youth are looking
forward to taking part in this great
humanitarian movement
we are pleased that the united arab
emirates will be part of the momentum
towards stability and the growth of
human potential
in a new civilized approach that opens
wide the doors of opportunity for those
who look forward
towards peace prosperity and the future
our societies today
possess the foundation of modern human
development
such as infrastructure a solid economy
and scientific achievements that will
enable them to advance the future of the
middle east
terminal
is
the united arab emirates believes that
the role of the united
states in the middle east is positive
and this belief is evidenced by the
accord that we are signing today at the
white house
for which you have taken the lead and
will remain a beacon in human history
for
all peace loving people around the world
and as for
us in the united arab emirates this
accord will enable us to continue to
stand by the palestinian people
and realize their hopes for an
independent state within a stable and
prosperous region
this accord builds upon previous peace
agreements signed by arab nations with
the state of israel
the aim of all these treaties is to work
towards stability and sustainable
development
in this difficult year when the world is
suffering from the
pre repercussions of the kavit 19
pandemic
my country the united arab emirates has
reinforced its humanitarian commitments
established by our nation's founding
father sheikh zayed who taught us
that standing with others regardless of
the religious or ethnic affiliation
is a humanitarian duty and a firm
principle
satan
[Applause]
during this difficult time the united
arab emirates my country was able to
launch the probe
a probe to mars the hope probe indeed
represents hope
that our region is capable of
advancement and progress
if governments and people embrace
science after the united arab emirates
sent
astronaut hazel al-mansuri last year as
the first arab
astronaut to reach the international
space station
and launched a peaceful nuclear power
plant
this accord opened up prospects for a
comprehensive piece
in the region
in
ladies and gentlemen peace requires
courage and shaping the future requires
knowledge
the advancement of nations requires
sincerity and persistence
we have come today to tell the world
that this is our approach
and that peace is our guiding principle
those who begin
things in the right way will reap pride
achievements with the grace of god thank
you
with the grace of god
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the minister of the
foreign affairs
of the kingdom of bahrain
mr president the first lady
prime minister your highness
ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon today
today is a truly historic occasion
a moment of hope and opportunity for all
the peoples
of the middle east and in particular
for the millions in our younger
generations
the declaration supporting peace between
the kingdom
of bahrain and the state of israel is an
historic step on the road to genuine
and lasting peace security and
prosperity across the region
and for all who live there regardless of
religion
sect ethnicity or
ideology
for too long the middle east has been
set back
by conflict and mistrust
causing untold destruction and thwarting
the potential of generations of
our best and brightest young people
now i'm convinced
we have the opportunity to change that
today's declaration was made possible
by the vision courage and commitment
of his majestic king
who supported by
[Applause]
supported by the people of bahrain has
protected
institutionalized and enhanced bahrain's
centuries-old spirit of coexistence
and harmony and has the wisdom to
recognize
that genuine cooperation is the most
effective means
to achieve peace and to safeguard
legitimate rights
thank you your majesty for this vision
of peace
for the region based on trust
respect and understanding between all
faiths
races and nations
to our brothers in the united arab
emirates i congratulate you
on your own momentous peace accord being
signed today
with israel his highness sheikh mohammed
bin zayed
has shown great leadership and foresight
to make peace possible
and secure a brighter future for our
[Applause]
region
for the state of israel and prime
minister netanyahu
we welcome and appreciate these steps
from you and your government recognizing
that enduring peace and security is only
possible
through a genuine engagement that
protects the rights
and interests of countries and peoples
in the region
in particular i want to express my deep
appreciation
to president donald trump
and his administration mr president
your statesmanship and tireless efforts
have brought us here today and made
peace
a reality
[Applause]
and to secretary pompeo senior adviser
jared kushner and special representative
evie brycovice who have
and others many others who have
carried out their mandates with
dedication
and skill ladies and gentlemen
today's agreement is an important
first step and it is now incumbent
on us to work urgently and actively
to bring about the lasting peace and
security
our peoples deserve a just
comprehensive and enduring two-state
solution
to the palestinian israeli conflict will
be the foundation
the bedrock of such peace
we have shown today
we have shown today that such a path
is possible even realistic
what was only dreamed of a few years ago
is now achievable and we can see before
us a golden opportunity for peace
security and prosperity for our region
let us together and with our
international partners
waste no time and seizing it thank you
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
the president of the united states the
prime minister
of the state of israel and his highness
the minister of foreign affairs
and international cooperation of the
united arab emirates
will sign a treaty of peace diplomatic
relations
and full normalization they will each
sign three copies
one in english hebrew and arabic
we kindly ask that all guests remain
seated
for the signing of the documents
[Music]
so which one
okay
thank you six years
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
congratulations
the president of the united states the
prime minister of the state of israel
and the minister of the foreign affairs
of the kingdom
of bahrain will now sign the declaration
of peace
they will each sign three copies one in
english
hebrew and arabic we kindly ask
that all guests remain seated for the
signing of the documents
down here
hmm
good
[Applause]
thank you
the president of the united states the
prime minister
of the state of israel his highness the
minister
of foreign affairs and international
cooperation
of the united arab emirates and the
minister of the foreign affairs of the
kingdom of bahrain
will now sign the abraham accords
they will each sign four copies one in
english
one in hebrew and two in arabic
uh
um
yes
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you